i have to tell you there are stories we
do on this show which are extremely
multifaceted in terms of what they mean
geopolitically sociologically all these
different things
and sometimes there is just a story
that
is too funny
at an absolute basic level
you all know about the big lie at this
point i'm sure this is the lie that joe
biden didn't really win the 2020
election
donald trump really won it it's
something trump and his followers have
been pushing
really since even before the 2020
election talking about mail-in ballot
fraud before the election even took
place um no evidence for any of it but
then they really got going with this
stuff on election night when trump came
out at 2 am and said we've basically won
it's over when that wasn't the case and
of course a couple days later it was
confirmed actually joe biden is the one
who won
the
claims range widely
from they stole votes digitally with
hackers or who knows
dead people voted
the mail-in ballots were fraudulent all
these different ideas no evidence for
any of it of course
over the weekend the former president
put out another one of these unhinged
statements
which now are appearing really just on
his website because he's banned on
twitter and he's banned on facebook and
all of it
and it actually is i would argue i'm
going to propose to you
this is the most unifying statement
that donald trump has ever made as a
result of grammatical error quite
there's really no other way to put it
donald trump's statement says and i'm
i'm just going to read it to you as
written
and then we're going to unravel the
grammar of it you really have to pick it
apart
trump says
anybody that doesn't think there wasn't
massive election fraud in the 2020
presidential election is either very
stupid or very corrupt
this is a trump statement i can agree
with now let's break it down um
we you have to really take apart the
grammar okay
so
trump says
anybody that doesn't think there wasn't
fraud is corrupt or stupid so if trump
had said
imagine this is the way i unravel these
double negatives if trump had said
anybody that thinks there wasn't fraud
is stupid that's really easy you don't
think there's fraud you're stupid
when trump says anybody that doesn't
think
there wasn't fraud trump is saying
if you believe that there's fraud
if you believe the big lie that's a
double negative
you're stupid or corrupt
and that is exactly right it actually i
was looking over the weekend i was
saying okay so wait
if you don't think it wasn't
this is a statement that i agree with
now sure double negative phrasing is
kind of weird
but trump is finally correct about
something here and this is of course the
ultimate self own
saved by syntax bizarrely enough and
it's surreal in some weird way when you
think that
this guy had the nuclear codes for four
years
could this be
the subconscious truth
that trump actually believes that if
you've
fallen for his lies
you are the stupid or corrupt one does
trump simply have no idea how double
negatives work
and
in a sense
it's the perfect unifying message if
you're able to unravel the double
negative the way we've just done and you
understand it you agree
if you're not able to unravel the double
negative maybe you also fell for the
voter fraud lie to begin with and so you
also agree with this statement it's it's
incredible that he has figured out a way
to really make a unifying statement that
just about everybody will believe
and we're supposed to believe
that he genuinely earned good grades
at the university of pennsylvania so
there it is if he does get back on
twitter
it will be a very very dark day
i love growing my own food at home many
of you have seen my gardening stuff on
my instagram i get great tips from the
audience and one of our sponsors is
lettuce grow which is by far the easiest
way to grow your own food at home
the lettuce grow farm stand is a
hydroponic unit that waters and
fertilizes itself you can grow more than
200 varieties of fruits and veggies at
home indoors or outdoors
i love my lettuce grow farm stand i've
grown edible flowers tomatoes
strawberries eggplant it only requires
five minutes of maintenance a week i can
grow 36 plants at a time it uses 95
percent less water than traditional
gardening no packaging
no waste i didn't even know it was
possible to grow food like this in a
portable unit but i love it and lettuce
grow is giving you fifty dollars off the
farm stand when you go to
lettucegrow.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below